I'll show you what it does then I
explain how it works that's right so I
just turn this handle that's what
happens I got some parts design off the
off the internet but then I have
modified a bit and everything was hand
drawn I didn't tell that computer files
for it's had to redraw love that so I
could then laser cut it by using
Inkscape sits a free open-source program
and then I used the knotting Nottingham
laser cutter to cut it so everything has
been laser cuts all the all the pipes
even the actual music that it's playing
has been laser cut I suppose I cheated
I'll use my software skills to do that I
actually wrote a program that converts
MIDI files into SVG's then I can load
the SVG into the laser cutter software
and because it's han't so SVG's like in
vector graphics that's first right the
laser cutter is only at one point two
meters wide so I can only cook one point
two meter strips so every so often like
what they're I've got a join that I have
to sell it sit together and then have to
actually use a scalpel to we cut the
holes where the joint is this took me
about three months to make yeah a lot of
that was actually doing doing all the
drawings for it's impairing all the
first laser cut off to be at the time
was rot right into the software to make
the rolls well that's all written in C
but to do that I had certain stand how
MIDI files work how the MIDI files ring
encoded took a little bit understanding
but being this knowledge to be able to
do that so MIDI files have a note on
note off and a velocity
velocities like the piano how hard you
press the key but on an organ you don't
have velocity sweeping nor that bits so
I just took in the MIDI file out to find
the note on and then further down the
files and note off get those match them
up and the note on it off gives you the
lens of the actual note that's played so
it starts off in the bottom of the organ
in the bottom of the organs these
bellows down here so as I turn the
handle those fellows go up and down they
create compressed air the compressed air
is then installed in this reservoir here
if I turn the handle can you see that
how that's Bill
that builds up air pressure no here
that's that's the what's called a spill
valve opening there that that peg
pressured a valve inside the reservoir
so the reservoir doesn't get open
pressurized and then at the top of the
organ if I engage the clutch which this
mechanism here when that's engaged the
handler also drives the paper along as
well Oh about four rolls now suggs so
that's a literal this has got the birdie
song and the chicken dance and entry of
the gladiators' which is the thing when
you think about clowns that's that's
what's normally playing in materials
about sixty pounds you materials I guess
in time to say about about three months
and obviously making more rolls is an
ongoing project I've just done it for
the fun of it
a GSM mobile phone we've built an entire
phone on our backs this year we've
deployed a our own GSM network across
the side six running a hundred megahertz
with a real cut-down Linux system at
boots in seven seconds and that's called
the hex engine and that is the core of
the controls